okay let's try to apply the CSS rules to
our Dom tree the first div rule would
set the text color to red which is a
property that cascades down to the hello
text this next rule makes the paragraph
contents to be displayed in black and
here's the font part
the rule applies to all paragraph nodes
regardless of its parent hence we change
the color of the text to black for hello
and world finally we get to our last
rule which tells us that any paragraph
node that has a div as its parent should
be hidden from the render tree as a
result we can prune this branch from a
render tree and all we're left with is
world so the final answer is world and
the text color is black